all right check out this first story
from timcast.com EU to impose mandatory
electricity cuts to flatten the curve
reduced reduced Peak energy demands
European commission had announced as
Russian price gaps as Putin threatens to
cut Europe off from all energy
deliveries the European Union has
announced plans for mandatory
electricity rationing with European
commission president Ursula Vander layen
telling reporters the EU must flatten
the curve of peak Energy prices
her announcement highlighted a
five-point plan the EU is preparing to
enact to address local energy markets
Europe has faced an energy crisis
following Russia cutting off supplies of
natural gas the funny thing is Russia is
now selling gas to China who is driving
it all the way back to Europe and crank
you know cranking up the cost and now
people are looking at like 500 energy
increases Italy you've got bars and
restaurants with candles and uh when you
look over at California and they're
doing the exact same thing it kind of
feels like what's happening there is
going to happen here and we're just a
little bit behind but I know Amela you
live in California right how's that yeah
unfortunately I do live in Los Angeles
so last night I was chilling in my
apartment and got a notification that
says you know due to our overwhelmed
electrical grid your electricity might
go out at any moment and you're gonna
have to deal with that for an hour or
two we'll rotate it across rotate it
across our different circuits and uh
welcome to the new world order here but
it didn't your power didn't go out it
didn't end up going out but uh I guess
they're putting out warnings that
through this continuous heat wave that
we're going through right now that
there's a very good possibility that's
going to happen and in other regions of
California they're doing those rotating
brownouts yeah if you saw you saw Gavin
Newsom though right yes right the police
sweater that was awesome yeah he's cold
okay maybe he's like you know it could
be that he's a lizard person you know
and then it's like it may be hot but yes
it still needs to I like that he's got
like really crazy tattoos of late yeah
he rips his sleeves off and he's just
got sleeves Yeah so basically after 4
P.M I heard Gavin doing did a video
maybe this is a video You're referencing
after 4 P.M that's like hot time that's
like Peak electricity turn off your what
everything except for your large
appliances yeah they're saying basically
try not to use AC if you can help it
cool your house or your apartment
beforehand don't turn on any larger
major appliances anything like that and
certainly don't charge your electric
cars even though we're gonna start
Banning gas vehicles in the coming years
have you heard of passive cooling you
ever studied any of that stuff no they
make like these uh I don't know if
they're made out of wood or out of cork
and then they'll like make all these
little like cuts through the Cork and
then you just pour water into the Cork
and then through it only works in really
dry environments okay but through
um I don't know evaporation the
evaporation it cools down the room by
like the water absorbs the heat from the
atmosphere to it'll get you from like
105 to 90 maybe you know it's for
desperate hot dry climate does we spit
in a studio apartment that's the
question yeah
we'll probably make one from cardboard
creative low energy evaporation uh air
conditioners you fill them with water
and then it basically yeah recently just
bought one of those although I don't
know after 4 pm if we can even have
those on you know here's a question why
don't you leave Los Angeles
oh you're getting in tricky territory
here so I do work for Prager you were
headquartered in Los Angeles Dennis's
fault you know Dennis who you had on the
show he's like I am not leaving
California he's like I'm I'm perfectly
fine being in California and I get it
he's also wearing a sweater
Dennis is chilling Dennis is chilling
and yeah you know I will say that being
in the heart of all the problems does
really get you invigorated every day to
be in the fight you know when you're
walking out of your apartment and a
homeless man screams obscenities at you
you're ready to work every single day
that's fair to learn how you gotta learn
self-defense yeah you've also got to
learn you know uh tactical poop cleanup
you know I don't know if you're gonna
step in it I'm 120 pounds soaking wet so
uh self-defense is something I need to
work on 100 yeah Jiu Jitsu yeah where
were you before La Florida oh wow yeah
you know what I like to think I thought
it through it was a fantastic
opportunity I love my job so much so
it's totally worth it don't get me wrong
but leaving the freedom State of Florida
to go to La which has just been
disintegrating in front of my eyes has
been an interesting you're on the front
lines you're on the front line you left
the Comfort I'm just imagining you
you're like you're at home in Florida
and you tell your family and you like
salute them and you're like I'm going to
the front line no I don't you're crazy
and I am going and then you go to
California yeah really bad which it's
hilarious because my mom is a super
radical left-leaning person so she would
love to have switched from Florida to
move over to Los Angeles and we've sort
of taken our opposite path your mom is
radical left because you said you were
too right I was too yeah did you
appreciate Florida while you were there
no this place is awful it's like I hate
this place did you did you get like hit
in the head with a turtle shell or
something and it just knocks sense into
you or what happened you know what so I
grew up my mom works for the political
left hi Mom she's not watching but hi
Mom definitely not watching uh so I grew
up with her influence and I I was
constantly told about the oppression
that I was going to face Living in
America she happens to be white so she
was telling me about like you know
you're black it's going to be a little
bit difficult for you things are going
to be hard and I totally fell for it
hook line and sinker graduated high
school started working as a youth
organizer and door knocking and telling
people who they needed to vote for I
worked on the Andrew Gillum campaign in
Florida yeah we all know how that turned
out like luckily my efforts went
unnoticed on that and eventually just
recognize so much hypocrisy that I had
to leave and started looking at other
views what made you realize like what
was the moment that you realized
something yeah so I grew up with my
white family and I was constantly going
to work and hearing about how awful
white people were and there were several
instances where it was just the most
blatant racist rhetoric you could hear
regarding somebody all towards white
people and I would go and work on these
projects and then go home to my white
family that had taken care of me my
entire life and I eventually confronted
one of the VPS at the organization and
said I don't get it man we're we said
we're tolerant we said we're anti-racist
we're literally working on these like
critical race Theory initiatives and he
basically told me you don't know how
oppressed you are and that's not my
fault so so it's like half your family
black guy for family white yes I wonder
because I I have a similar experience I
come from a mixed mixed race family so
I'm a quarter I'm a quarter Asian and my
experience was was similar in that I go
out and I hear these lefties saying
things like white people are bad and I'm
like hey wait a minute like I got white
family right and not white family and
I'm pretty sure you're full of sh you
know what I mean ish yeah yeah like this
and then what I end up actually seeing
growing up is the policies they put in
place they claim help help racism
actually just end up hurting my family
and my family was the epitome of like
opposing racism right a hundred percent
I went through the exact same experience
I actually grew up in a really rural
conservative small town never truly
experienced an ounce of racism in my
life but was so dedicated to the idea
that I was oppressed in this country
that I like fought people about it and I
I I
basically labeled myself as a victim and
went around the world telling everybody
about how victimized I was but so so
when you go to your family and you're
like hey I don't believe this stuff
because like you know we're a mixed
family and clearly the white people in
my family are good people this is not
true yeah well so my mom and dad got
divorced when I was sick so I was
basically just with my mother's
influence and I went to her and I was
like hey Mom I think I might be a little
conservative and she hated it and we
went through what's the liberal
equivalent of sprinkling he was holy
water yeah
she's like what can I do to stop this
from happening because I was like her
little Protege in a lot of ways working
at the same organization she was working
for so you know her her head blew
through the roof and we went through
months of just contentious arguments
over all these different subject matters
and eventually she was like okay this is
my daughter I think she's pretty
strong-willed about what she believes
right now and I'm just gonna leave it
alone maybe we don't talk politics yeah
I went through something similar with my
mom and I realized after like five or
six years that it was more about the
tone that we were communicating it was
more about you know less about trying to
be right or just listening but he and
red pulled his mom yeah but it took 12
years and it was like we almost our
relationship almost ended and she got
really sick from stress like it was
horrible when you go at it and you're
like obsessed with trying to convince
someone they can get really really ill
it can really hurt people so the best is
just to exist and listen and the cult
the the cult is scary I agree yeah I I
realize that just through living my life
with my values I think it would sort of
influence her a little bit like she's
now come around and said you know what
I'm I think I'm comfortable being
friends with people who are conservative
which for her it's a big great big step
I mean when I say she's radical leftist
I mean as far left as you could possibly
be so yeah but like authoritarian or
libertarian
authoritarian authoritarian because like
the libertarian left in my opinion
doesn't really exist like they do but
it's such an impossible political
standard that most people on the left
abandon it right but then claim their
libertarian left to try and Win Win
votes so they can then enslave you you
know what I mean yeah I mean with all
the policing you want to do of people's
speech and how they act and what they do
it's hard not to be authoritarian in
that sense do you know political Compass
memes there's like a couple different
pages yeah oh is it like the little test
that you take that puts you yeah yeah
the memes are hilarious and it's like
one of the one of the one place on the
internet where they actually understand
what the political Compass actually
means and you'll actually see like the
left and the right arguing with each
other but laughing at these jokes and I
did a I did a mini rant once where I
said
woke people are not libertarian left
every single time people come out and
talk about antifa or something they
claim it's a Libertarian left and I'm
like dude it is not libertarian to go
around bashing people over the skull
demanding they live the way they want
you to live that's authoritarian left
libertarian left is like hippies living
on a farm being like you want to share
this watermelon with me dude the problem
is supporting that is extremely
difficult and it doesn't scale scale
very well but the political Compass
means people were like Tim is correct
and they they put my face on the liberal
left quadrant arguing why antifa and
woke people are not libertarian left and
everybody agreed like all these
different people were like yeah that's
that's literally like woke people are
authoritarian Kami socialist types right
as soon as you start trying to impose
your worldview on anybody you can't call
yourself a Libertarian right that's why
it was really funny when um was it
Jorgensen the libertarian candidate said
yeah Joe jargon said it's not enough to
not be racist we must be actively
anti-racist but I was like the
libertarian candidate telling people
what they must to do is deliciously
ironic what is the libertarian version
of wokeness
well what was this ideological yeah so
there's no there's no limit the Liberty
uh if you were woke and you were a
Libertarian you'd say something like you
know I think you know critical race
Theory and these things are good how can
we you know work with each other on
trying to implement what I agree with
and then they say I disagree with you
and it's like oh okay well we disagree
let's figure out how to live together
see I totally get along with those
people I met I met a communist guy he
did he you know I was in Berkeley he
denounced antifa he said the violence is
wrong they shouldn't be doing that he's
like true communism would be us living
together working together and I was like
oh we're friends I was like bro you can
be a communist I don't care as long as
you're not bashing people over the skull
you know and it really is as simple as
that and they think we're were far worse
than they make us out to be these
horrible villains but really I'm like
you can believe whatever you want to
believe just please don't come into my
territory and impose it on me right but
that's how a lot of voc ideology works
it right needs compliance and it needs
you to agree to be a part of it if
anyone questions it then their system is
broken yep and that's unacceptable
that's what I love about like this weird
world where the mainstream corporate
press calls every single person far
right or right wing and it's like it's
just so weird that every single
ideological Viewpoint is right wing like
all of them if you're a communist and
you're woke you're left but if you're a
communist and you're not woke you're far
right if you're a socialist
and you're anti-corporate you're far
right Jimmy Dore who's like a socialist
is right wing that that one blew my mind
I'm like okay y'all jump look you want
to come at me and say Tim pool's right
wing or whatever I'll bet you can make
an argument about center right or
something even though I'm like in the
middle but Jimmy Dore he's like
Universal Health Care and like all these
other left policies but then he goes the
Democrats and the Republicans are
corporatists who are selling you out not
that he's far right right but they just
moved the center to a place where
they're like look all the way over there
is Extreme far right whereas it wouldn't
have been you know a decade ago two
decades ago we just migrated it so far
that we don't understand where the
middle is at all we just gotta ignore
them yeah I love the buzzwords kind of
kind of let the buzzwords flow through
you the alt the left the right the the
authoritarian the libertarian like you
don't fall into a group like we're not
putting you in a in a in a holding cell
right now because of what label we
slapped on your chest it doesn't that
stuff's not relevant in humanity Jimmy's
a great example of that because he talks
so much you see the intricacies of of
who he is and he doesn't he's way all
over the place as he believes what he
believes right Jimmy has left I just
think we have to ignore what the cult
thinks because the woke cult is not left
or right like this this is what I was
saying people some people don't don't
agree but I'm like
sterilizing your kids is not a left wing
or right-wing position it is of the left
right now but the left is like
it's it's usually a reference to
revolutionary or economically flat
systems communism for instance the
farthest left you go on the political
Compass whereas right is laissez-faire
capitalism those as the economics field
I think Jimmy is a bit revolutionary
he's got that revolutionary state of
mind but I also I can tell that he
appreciates uh like the state when it
functions properly he likes that kind of
stuff and he's willing to use the state
to you know accommodate people this is
and that's more authoritarian versus
libertarian the state versus you know no
State and the thing that always confused
me when it was is when they say like
laissez-faire capitalists are far right
and so are Nazis and I'm like but they
completely disagree on like everything
how does that make sense what does that
even mean and they say things like that
they're always trying to redefine what
left and right is in order to justify
why you're not left or whatever so I'm
just like we got to be careful about
putting people in camps that's what that
is is the first step on the path to
putting people in camps is giving them
labels and putting them in a
Consciousness box when it comes to I
think cult is often a good word I know
it's a strong word but it's a good word
because as soon as you start to deviate
on even one single issue they throw you
out and label you as something and
language is so powerful for the woke
left in particular the way they
manipulate it the way they utilize it in
order to put people in certain groups
and label them and as soon as we go you
know I'm not going to accept the label
and I'm not going to take that I think
it's when we start changing the game a
little bit thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there